five days after the fatal helicopter
crash that killed basketball star Kobe
Bryant reports are emerging that the
crafts operating company was not
certified to fly in poor visibility
heavy fog is said to have contributed to
the accident
Bryant his teenage daughter and seven
others were killed the island Express
helicopters company was reportedly only
certified to operate in conditions where
the pilot could see outside the aircraft
well the LA Lakers are planning to hold
a pregame tribute to their former star
player when they returned to the court
Friday night for their first game since
his death a memorial in the making to
Kobe Bryant and his daughter Gianna this
Los Angeles artist known as Cable has
been working on it
for only a few days he's not sure when
he'll finish it Cable has painted other
murals in LA but this one is different
if I kind of like my first time doing
like somebody like a tribute and wow
it's like so much energy out here in the
street you know people like coming
together like I feel like it's like a
place where people can actually like
gather and kind of like like embrace
each other the loss of the basketball
star his daughter and seven others in
last Sunday's helicopter crash has
devastated fans working on the mural has
given cable time to come to terms with
the tragedy and focus on what legacy
Kobe leaves behind he inspired a lot of
people and and hopefully he his death
tonight and I know I won't like going
vain you know like people were like like
a fear of future athletes future artists
will were like emerging there you know
inspired by pious person across town in
Central Los Angeles heartbroken fans
have created a memorial outside the
Staples Center the basketball arena
where Kobe's former team the LA Lakers
played their home games his death has
resulted in an outpouring of grief
as the day turns tonight the mourners
multiply many have spoken of how they
followed Kobe's entire 20-year career
playing until his retirement in 2016 as
the NBA's third highest all-time scorer
for each and every fan
Kobe even though at times shrouded in
controversy was special and his death
aged 41 came too soon it's not just Kobe
the the championship winner the MVP the
all-star it's you know we lost a family
member la Los Angeles lost a family
member he's gonna leave the legacy of an
amazing father I think and so much more
than just basketball obviously he won an
Oscar he did a lot more so I think he's
is gonna be I can't even put it into
words but the biggest thing that LA ever
lost Southern California ever lost cuz
we all loved him and we're gonna miss
him greatly what he me for us is that
anybody you can do it anyone can do it
you know just because you're black or
white or Hispanic it doesn't matter you
can do what you want to do and Kobe
Bryant show us that being a young black
man you can do whatever you put your
mind to the LA Lakers will play their
first game since Kobe's death on Friday
night an emotional time for fans who are
determined to never forget their hero